take responsibility for the chaos that's
unfolding of course i take
responsibility i'm president but i was
horrible what to see as you saw to see
people treat it like they did horses
barely running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
president biden vowed there would be
payback last year after images of border
patrol agents using whips
caused uproar and false accusations dhs
said there would be a quick probe but
six months later that investigation is
still ongoing with no information
released here to react former acting dhs
secretary chad wolfe chad morning to you
good morning you would think that an
investigation like that would take maybe
a week two weeks
it looks like it's taken six months and
we may never know the results of it
because what the president said
did not happen
well that's exactly right and at the
time if you recall the dhs secretary
secretary mayorka said the investigation
would be
closed in a matter of weeks we're now
six months
the you know not only does the dhs
secretary owe an apology to those border
patrol officers but also the president
the vice president who also made
disparaging comments and so
i've been briefed on many of these types
of investigations it does not take six
months when all the facts are on video
you have access to those border patrol
agents down there on the border you can
get into investigation you can close it
pretty quickly
but i think it's going to reveal that
they did not do anything wrong the video
shows that eyewitness accounts show that
i just don't think that the
administration wants to admit that well
the photographer who took the images in
question said quote nobody saw a border
patrol agent whipping and that's
that was uh the whole thing and you know
it it shouldn't take six months to have
that guy come out and say that uh
something else we wanted to uh
pick your brain on and that is coming up
on april 1st it sounds like title 42 is
going to end and it looks like as many
as 170 000 refugees
could be heading into the country
where do we put them
yeah
well it's a great question so title 42
was always a temporary measure it was
always going to go away but
unfortunately what this administration
has not done is they haven't planned for
it they haven't put any other policies
in place to deter the illegal activity
that we see so not only do you have the
the amount of folks that are coming to
the border every month 100 and you know
70 80 100 000 but you also have the
surge that's going to come once the
cartels and the smugglers and others
start advertising that title 42 has gone
away so it's going to be a double whammy
and again this administration should
have planned for this better they should
have put procedures in place and
unfortunately what they continue to do i
just don't understand and i don't
believe it is they continue to treat
this as though it's a capacity issue and
if they throw more resources and more
bodies at it they can process these
individuals faster and that's not
addressing the underlying cause of the
illegal behavior and the pull factors
that are causing a lot of these
individuals to continue to break the law
month after month after month sure and
after they are processed as we are
looking at right there in brownsville
texas then they are released into the
interior
and then they are told hey go to an ice
office but as we have heard oftentimes
they don't
yeah that's right that's right they have
they've broken the system along that
border it's overwhelmed and so they will
they will release individuals into the
country we don't see them showing up we
know that 80 to 85 percent of them will
never qualify for asylum and so we we're
going to have to remove them from the
country all right let's see what happens
chad thank you very much
all right thank you you bet